first Republicans in Congress are
demanding an investigation into
Christopher Steele he's the author of
the infamous Trump dossier that has
dominated politics in this country for
an entire year
fox chief intelligence correspondent
catherine herridge is all over this
story and she joins us tonight
well Thank You Tucker this case matters
because it's the first known criminal
referral from Congress as part of the
Russia investigations the Republican
chairman of the Senate Judiciary
Committee chuck Grassley who was
oversight for the FBI and Justice
Department along with his Senate
colleague Senator Lindsey Graham believe
there is a violation of 18 USC which is
lying to federal authorities commonly
known as the Martha Stewart statute
according to the letter made public
today the senators believe potential
violations for false statements relate
to Christopher Steele's distribution of
the unverified Trump dossier a
half-dozen major media outlets were
briefed before the election Steele was
on the payroll of opposition research
firm fusion GPS whose co-founder is
former journalist Glenn Simpson in the
months leading up to the election
Simpson told steel to brief reporters at
least twice after no reporters ran with
the story the project was of course
funded by the DNC and Clinton campaign
senator Grassley said the criminal
referral is about a perceived double
standard Trump campaign associates were
prosecuted for lying to the FBI and the
same standard should apply to others
regardless of politics tonight a senior
Senate Democrat Richard Blumenthal
called the referral partisan and said
the Russian investigation was triggered
by information entirely separate from
the dossier car catherine herridge
thank you very much for that